of course Kent Pruitt dying over the
weekend big news for us here at bloomers
surveillance we've known about this for
months it Ken was very very ill and
because you two were such a great team
on Bloomberg radio go in the room I was
so timid that voice and mr. Tom just be
polite don't I'll have a tantrum when
you go in and Ken didn't miss a beat
integrations two people don't realize
that you came to this as a beginner ken
was the pro who had been doing it for
years and you started out you struggled
a little bit and then they put Ken with
you and it just clicked well we did that
you know we did Bloomberg on the economy
which you did as well and of course you
had decades of experience coming back to
rayovac and Gorbachev and here was this
guy who was a radio guy back I think he
did the Civil War he was epi' Maddox and
I walked into a guy that was totally a
class act totally gracious and totally
patient with me he and we would really
get going what's great about this we
hope to give you here for a couple of
minutes folks some of the vignettes that
that we knew is is he would keep it
under he was such a pro he would keep
his fury under guard whether it was
politics or dealing with me well anybody
who knew him knew that he was the
ultimate gentleman and not only was he a
gentleman he looked like a gentleman
with his silver hair his tall proud
bearing he was the epitome of the
Southern gentleman I'm not going to say
which side he probably would have been
on had he been at Appomattox since he
grew up in North Carolina yeah I mean I
don't know which side he would have been
on but you know there was a civil war
between us and you know as I've said
many times there's almost like a
marriage where Ken got the love notes
and I got the hate mail but within all
this was the craft that he brought to
it's so different from what you do or I
do he didn't do economics like Michael
McKee
he wasn't the sophisticate of the moment
it was very common man yes and the thing
about Kendall was he knew what he was
talking about he had done business news
for years but he didn't get into the
minutia he remembered the viewer he
remembered the listener the person who
didn't know as much as you two knew and
he was always after you and after
me to explain to people what was going
on you know III look at you know Brad
hints or someone at Sanford Bernstein or
any of the other people that we would
interview and what would drive me nuts
is I'd be going blah blah
u6 you know rate or return first
derivative and their turn going can ask
me something in English please that they
could understand I've talking to a lot
of people who knew him over the last
couple of weeks and they universally
praised coming on with him they love to
talk to him because he would bring out
the best in them without getting into
too much into the weeds he would allow
them to explain what people needed to
know in order to understand what you
were talking about but if he didn't have
his more tea coffee he was surly within
the grind that we do here and of course
you're doing Bloomberg first word now on
radio and you know we do surveillance
but the grind of it he literally taught
me better how to do three or four or
five hours straight he taught you how to
take a nap he would go nuts that I
didn't think he would be Wednesday's
he'd be time you gotta stop doing that
you need a damn nap well he would go
home and take a nap and then he would
get out and do some of the things he
loved to do he'd love to get out to the
country he had a place up in the man's
and he loved to go fishing and some of
my favorite stories from Ken were about
fishing and the time he spent on the
rivers and lakes
he would go and of course he had stock
lines and it would bore us with the
death but one of them what you did with
him as well as to go out to Wyoming and
is he would say look for a trout the
size of your leg and but he really
didn't I mean he was the real deal when
it came to fishing absolutely and of
course he was actually kind of a quiet
small-town boy who made his career in
the big city and did it so very very
well you know Kent Pruitt passing away
here after a long illness our regards
thank you many cuz my get me through
this place Tom we got to say goodbye to
Ken and thanks to Ken for everything he
contributed to us and to making our
careers what they are today and we wish
the best to his wife